[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend aus moskau kam heute zwei
meldungen zum einen hat der kreml ein
einreiseverbot für spitzenvertreter der
europäischen union und eben
parlamentarier verhängt nun gut russland
ist derzeit ja wohl eh nicht so ein
attraktives reiseziel weitaus wichtiger
als diese diplomatische provokation oder
revanche ist das dekret das bleibt mir
putin zum thema gas unterschrieben hat
dazu kommen wir im verlauf der sendung
noch ausführlicher blicken jetzt aber
erst in die ukraine überdies über die
situation dort habe ich vorhin mit
wladimir klitschko gesprochen zuvor
berichtet petra otto welche nachrichten
und bilder uns heute vom krieg
erreichten die nachrichten aus mariupol
auch heute kaum erträglicher als all die
letzten tage und wochen die geschätzt
170.000 menschen die noch da sind in der
zerbombten stadt versuchen zu überleben
die flucht korridore sie funktionieren
wesentlich schleppender als erhofft
zumindest ist jetzt wohl ein hilfskonvoi
unterwegs und der präsident ruft nach
unterstützung und nach waffen heute per
videobotschaft im parlament in holland
verschleppungen massaker bomben auf
krankenhäuser all das muss beantwortet
werden von der demokratischen
gemeinschaft
rund um kiew wie hier in profi auch in
den letzten tagen zerstörung und nichts
zu spüren von einem rückzug russischer
truppen in der hauptstadt selbst ist es
vielleicht etwas ruhiger geworden die
innenstadt inzwischen komplett
verbarrikadiert die bevölkerung wachsam
bewaffnet und gewappnet für den feind
ich bin für meine enkel wer meine kinder
für die freiheit
keiner hilft uns wenn wir uns nicht
selbst helfen
seine aufrufe und auftritte all die
durchhalteparolen sie werden seit wochen
gehört wir werden unsere stadt
verteidigen wir denken nicht daran sie
zu verlassen es ist unser zuhause
der bürgermeister auch sein bruder
wladimir
zweimal schwergewicht unerschrocken
treiben die beiden das volk zum
widerstand an und wladimir klitschko ist
heute auf mission in deutschland
ja mit wladimir klitschko der auf reise
ist in berlin mit der ukrainischen
delegation wollen wir jetzt sprechen
guten abend klitschko amt wir haben
ihnen nachrichten dass kiew extrem
beschossen wird aus der luft in den
letzten 24 stunden also auch keinen
rückzug in irgendeiner form von den
russen wie mal angekündigt ist
entspricht das auch ihrer
informationslage sie kommen ja direkt
aus kiew heute ja ich bin heute
ausgiebig um in den letzten 35 tagen
wird das ganze land beschlossen bis 2000
raketen sind von belarus russland
abgeschossen wurden und auf die ukraine
dabei wird mit
maschine bombentypen das leben zerstört
die infrastruktur zerstört kinder
getötet zivilisten getötet
infrastruktur
die kraft
atomkraftwerken ins vorgesetzt wurden
und viel mehr es ist ein brutales
sinnlose krieg der bis jetzt kein ende
hat wenn man davon hört ganze
friedengespräche abzug der kräfte wie
verstehen sie wissen wie russische
politik ist alles was gesagt wird man
muss mit dem gegenteil erreichen wenn
gesagt wird wir greifen kein land an und
die ukraine haben wir nicht angegriffen
es ist leider das gegenteil davon haben
sie das heute auch so in ihren
gesprächen mit dem kanzleramtsminister
und mit der wirtschaftsminister habe
gesagt dass man bitte hier wirklich
gucken soll wie man mit russland umgeht
und was man dort überhaupt noch glaubt
wir verteidigen die
demokratische werte die wir in freien
welt in europa haben
in der ukraine verteidigen wir das mit
unseren und zahlen mit menschlichen
leben
wir in der ukraine
brauchen unterstützung wir haben schon
viel bekommen vor allem von deutschland
und deswegen möchte ich mich bedanken
und ich muss auch sagen es ist nicht
genug
es ist nie genug weil
der angreifer der größe macht immer
weiter
immer mehr truppen immer mehr waffen
werden an die grenzen und in das land
gezogen und deswegen brauchen wir
unterstützung von der westlichen welt
die wirtschaft in der ukraine ist flach
die steuer werde nie bezahlt die badges
wären nicht aufgefüllt überauchen
finanzen als unterstützung wir brauchen
lebensmittel als unterstützung wir
brauchen medikamenten als unterstützung
brauchen waffen als unterstützung wir
brauchen eine isolierung von russland
eine isolation von russland
wirtschaftliche situation weil jeder
cent der auch für gas bezahlen wird für
waffen verwendet die heute zählen unsere
kinder unsere frauen unsere männer unter
zivilisten
gilt unsere leben haben sie die
assistenz haben sie denn zusagen
bekommen heute in ihren gesprächen also
reisen sie dann wieder ab mit dem gefühl
durchgedrungen zu sein etwas erreicht zu
haben
ich muss sagen dass die gespräche
natürlich
gut waren
tischtennis
ist da
empathie ist da nur jetzt endlich wir
müssen zutaten kommen wir können nicht
wochenlang monatelang warten
wir müssen schnell agieren als
gemeinschaft
wir sind nur gemeinsam stark
weil diese vision russland und der
gegner in dem sinne der gräser in dem
sinne ist enorm stark
natürlich ausdauer schlägt klasse und
talent und jede stärke aber dass
ausdauer hat auch ein ende wir haben
einen riesen willen in der ukraine
diesen widerstand zu leisten
wenn wir mit leben der
bevölkerungszahlen und
unsere willis stärker als jede waffe und
armee aber das hat auch gewisse grenzen
wenn wir nicht unterstützung bekommen
deswegen es ist unglaublich notwenig die
weitere unterstützung
letztendlich wir kriegen es sehen
diese krieg läuft desto stärker werden
wer jeden tag zählt aber auch jeden tag
wird menschliches leben verloren
deswegen es muss jetzt agiert werden
jetzt entscheidungen getroffen werden
wir können nicht mehr lange warten es
muss jetzt passieren deswegen bin ich
hier in berlin deswegen führe ich die
ganze gespräch deswegen
sehen wir so stark wenn der gemeinsame
es tun kehren sie jetzt dann zu ihrem
bruder
vitali und zu präsident selensky zurück
um die beiden weiter zu unterstützen
natürlich werde ich zurück in die
ukraine sein so schnell wie die
gespräche gelaufen sind natürlich
möchten wir von den gesprächen wie
gesagt daten sehen und haben
weil meine
landsfrauen männer landsleuten
landsleute warten auf diese
unterstützung jetzt und wie gesagt ist
es an unterschiedlichen stellen wir
brauchen diese unterstützung an
geschichtlichen seiten es muss jetzt
passieren
in anderen in verschiedenen städten es
gibt keinen strom im lebensmittel kein
wasser kein existenz kein leben
und die ukraine ist nicht weit man denkt
es ist irgendwo die ukraine wenn man
noch nie dagewesen aber wenn wir über
champions-league-finale nachdenken
eurovision song contest euro cup 2012
und viel mehr musik festivals und viel
mehr dann natürlich weiß man deswegen
europa sind wir sind im herzen
geografisch von europa und die sind das
frei freundlich erfolg wir haben keinen
angegriffen wir sind angegriffen worden
wir haben keinem was böses getan ist es
leider das böse tut für uns serie es tut
uns das ist ein kauf ist ein kauf das
gute wir gegen das böse russland us
armee ich habe nicht gegen das russische
volk aber ich habe gegen das jüdische
volk
nichts tun
diese propaganda wie gift
für das
gehirn das für stillstand empathie und
deswegen
denken die russen das wäre oder dass die
in ein land gehen wo narzissen leben
wenn man darüber
nachdenkt wir haben einen präsidenten
mit jüdische russin
wir sind ein land der kreativ tun nicht
destruktiv ist
wir sind ein land der seit 2014 nach
freiheit strebt freiheit die
entscheidung freiheit in freiheit zu
leben
freiheit und demokratische werte das
wofür wir streben dafür wir stehen wofür
wir kämpfen
jetzt gut das war ein eindringlicher
appell auch der auch hier in diesem land
sicherlich gehört wird von vielen
millionen zugesehen haben jetzt ich
danke ihnen passen sie gut auf sich auf
danke für die unterstützung und bitte
machen sie weiter wir brauchen das danke
die ukraine jedenfalls hat deutschland
schon seit vielen jahren davor gewarnt
gehabt sich von russlands gas abhängig
zu machen gewarnt welche absichten putin
verfolgt er wiederum verkündete heute
dass es ab freitag definitiv noch gas
gegen rubel geben werde das klingt
allerdings weitaus kategorischer also
ist auf den zweiten blick ist die
häscher mit den hintergründen
erst soll ein katz und maus spiel
bleiben in moskau teil der russische
präsident in seiner ihm eigenen
deutlichkeit mit was ab morgen gelten
soll gas nur noch gegen rubel
um an gas zu gelangen müssten
ausländische kunden jubel konnten bei
der gazprombank eröffnen erklärt putin
wenn diese zahlungen nicht erfolgen
werden wir das als vertragsbruch werten
mit allen nötigen konsequenzen der
bundeskanzler hat zur selben zeit besuch
aus österreich gestern erst hatte scholz
mit putin telefoniert dabei soll der
russische präsident ihm dargelegt haben
dass zahlungen weiterhin in euro
geleistet werden könnten nach einer
reuters meldung hat herr putin gerade
gesagt ab morgen muss in rubel bezahlt
werden könnten sie bitte noch mal sagen
was jetzt ihre befürchtungen sind wir
haben die verträge angeschaut über die
gaslieferung und die anderen lieferung
darin steht drin dass in euro gezahlt
wird manchmal dollar ab in der regel in
euro und ich habe in dem gespräch mit
dem russischen präsidenten klar gemacht
dass das auch so bleiben wird und wie
seine vorstellungen sind dass das
geschehen kann
das ist das was wir jetzt genau
anschauen werden aber auf alle fälle
gilt für die unternehmen dass sie in
euro zahlen wollen können und werden
bislang läuft das gasgeschäft mit
russland so ab gazprom liefert gas an
deutsche energieversorger die bezahlen
in euro an die gazprombank die bank ist
bislang nicht sanktioniert unklar ist
wie sich putins erlass ab morgen
westliche käufer müssten ein zweites
konto eröffnen ein google konto auf das
ihre euro transferiert und umgetauscht
werden
ich habe das gefühl dass das ein trick
ist eine list und das ist sehr wichtig
unter dem gesichtspunkt wie sich putin
für das russische publikum darstellen
kann nämlich als jemand der europa seine
bedingungen aufzwingen kann
ein pr erfolg für moskau der
wirtschaftsminister kannte putins neue
rubel pläne noch nicht als er heute
grundsätzliches formulierte wichtig ist
für uns dass wir nicht das signal geben
wir lassen uns von putin erpressen und
was sie dann mit dem geld machen ist
solange die banken nicht sanktionen
unterliegen weitestgehend hier bier ein
grundsatz der sich beweisen muss das
machtspiel um die gasimporte geht weiter
euro oder rubel
ein sofortiges embargo gegen russland
hält berlin ja wegen der
wirtschaftlichen folgen bislang für
nicht verantwortbar die furcht nicht nur
der bundesregierung vor einem abrupten
ende der gaslieferungen aus russland
hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen dass
dieser krieg zu einem zeitpunkt kommt an
dem die deutsche wirtschaft sich noch
nicht von der korona pandemie erholt hat
durch die massiven finanzhilfen sind
gewaltige stark schulden aufgelaufen wie
die deutsche bundesbank heute
vorgerechnet hat und kann man schulden
zwar auch wieder abtragen nach der
weltfinanzkrise 2008 ist das zum
beispiel gelungen daran erinnert oliver
reichert und erklärt warum die lage
diesmal aber eine andere ist worüber ich
danach auch mit dem bundesfinanzminister
spreche
was hat die finanz und wirtschaftskrise
mit der kogit pandemie gemeinsam richtig
diese beiden groß krisen haben den start
jeweils hunderte von milliarden euro
gekostet
die entwicklung des deutschen
schuldenberges während der pandemie
wachsen die schulden des deutschen
staates um 429 milliarden euro und die
pandemie ist ja noch nicht zu ende
während der finanz und wirtschaftskrise
steigen die deutschen staatsschulden um
499 milliarden euro also eine ähnliche
größenordnung
diese beiden mega krisen der letzten
zehn jahre sind für den auswirkungen für
die wirtschaft vergleichbar ein
weltweiter schock der jeweils das
potenzial hat in abwärtsspirale für die
gesamte volkswirtschaft zu führen wenn
man aber die heutige wirtschaftsleistung
mit den kurven schulden ins verhältnis
setzt sehen die folgen der pandemie
weniger schlimm aus
am ende der finanz- und wirtschaftskrise
machen die schulden des deutschen
staates 82 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts aus nur 69,3
prozent sind es dagegen jetzt in der
endphase der pandemie
wir haben auch eine sehr starke
wirtschaftliche entwicklung gehabt
gerade was den arbeitsmarkt angeht ist
sehr sehr gut wir haben immer wieder
rekordzahlen bei der erwerbstätigkeit
erlebt das hilft den staatsfinanzen das
hilft auch dem bruttoinlandsprodukt
angela merkel und ihren finanzministern
gelang es nach der bankenkrise ohne groß
zu sparen die schulden wieder abzubauen
die wirtschaft wuchs spülte geld in die
staatskassen die schulden würden
sozusagen weg gewachsen hier geht es um
und über die steigerung der
wirtschaftskraft von jahr zu jahr kommt
mehr bruttoinlandsprodukt hinzu und
darauf
relativieren sich die schulden am
24 februar beginnt eine katastrophe eine
neue krise sie trifft auch die
wirtschaft die hart weiß noch niemand
wegen des krieges und seiner
wirtschaftlichen folgen werden
zusätzliche schulden gemacht
wir sehen jetzt schon direkt folgen
dieses krieges auf die staatsfinanzen
das hat zum einen mit den energiepreisen
zu tun der staat hat jetzt ja auch
entlastungs paket beschlossen und das
kostet geld das belastet die
öffentlichen haushalte dass wir zu neuen
schulden führen ebenso die mehrausgaben
für verteidigung stichwort ist hier das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr von
100 milliarden euro die politik kämpft
mit viel geld gegen die krise an das hat
sich bewährt der verlauf des krieges
aber ist unabsehbar
viele unwägbarkeiten auch für den
bundesfinanzminister mit dem jetzt
sprechen wollen christian lindner sonst
zugeschaltet guten abend herr lindner
guten abend frau slomka ja da haben wir
jetzt schon einen riesigen schuldenberg
dank pandemie und jetzt kommt auch noch
ein krieg hinzu mit unwägbaren folgen
muss man sich nicht jetzt war ich auch
ehrlich machen und sagen schwarze null
schuldenbremse leute das ist schön aber
daraus wird jetzt bis auf weiteres
nichts
slomka gerade im gegenteil wir haben
einen stark gestiegenen schuldenstand
wir haben auch aufgrund des krieges in
der ukraine jetzt noch zusätzliche
aufgaben die wir schultern müssen umso
mehr wird es die aufgabe sein in den
nächsten jahren rechtzeitig auch wieder
den weg in die finanzpolitische
normalität zu finden
der staat muss er aus seinen schulden
herauswachsen um für zukünftige krisen
gerüstet zu sein und die belastungen für
die jungen nicht zu weit zu erhöhen dass
man natürlich schön sondern da aus der
krise wieder heraus wachsen könnte sowie
das nach der weltfinanzkrise 2008
gelungen ist aber nach wachstum und auf
niedrigen zinsen die das dann ja auch
die dem staat ja auch dann helfen sieht
es im moment überhaupt nicht aus man
sich anguckt was hier auf uns zu kommt
in den nächsten ja wir wissen es nicht
monaten oder jahren sie haben absolut
recht die aufgabe ist enorm und
möglicherweise noch größer als im
vergangenen jahrzehnt umso mehr müssen
wir zweierlei dinge tun zum einen
sollten wir alles einsetzen was wir
haben um die wirtschaftliche dynamik zu
stärken um dr schulung nach der korona
pandemie jetzt zu beschleunigen also
keine steuererhöhungen sondern eher
entlastung weniger bürokratisch muss vor
allen dingen schnellere staatliche
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren damit
zum beispiel neue betriebe auch schränke
hilfen für unternehmen
auch kurzfristig direkte hilfen für
besonders betroffene unternehmen ja und
auf der anderen seite müssen wir
dazu übergehen sobald es eben geht auch
die schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes
wieder einzuhalten dass auch keine
unverbindliche politische entscheidung
sondern ein gebot der verfassung wird
man sehen wie sich das entwickelt ein
großes fragezeichen ist wie geht es mit
dem energiefragen weiter wie geht es mit
dem gas weiter und gibt es jetzt dieses
ominöse dekret von herrn putin der sagt
ab freitag noch in rubel hat aber
gleichzeitig mit seiner kreativen
doppelten kontoführung auch eine
möglichkeit geschaffen dass die europäer
weiterhin den euro zahlen dann wird es
den buben umgetauscht vereinfacht gesagt
das ist eigentlich ein trick 17 nummer
und nach die deutsche bundesregierung
damit für uns gelten die verträge
verträge sind verträge die verträge
lauten auf euro und dollar und
dementsprechend sollte auch nur in euro
und dollar gezahlt werden irgendeine
form von politischer erpressung durch
putin ist nicht akzeptabel ist das nicht
durch die hintertür also wir beweisen
dann den euro auf ein konto bei der
nicht mit sanktionen behängten gas komme
und die verweist das dann auf ein
anderes konto und dann kommt es in rubel
bei herrn putin an ist doch unterläuft
doch eigentlich das was man wollte das
werden wir technisch prüfen aber die
politische aussage ist klar es gibt kein
entgegenkommen für wladimir putin die
bestehenden verträge werden erfüllt und
wir wollen nicht erlauben dass die
harten sanktionen auch gegen die
russische zentralbank unterlaufen wird
wir wollen russland politisch finanziell
und wirtschaftlich isolieren und
maximalen druck auf putin ausüben damit
baldmöglichst seine aggressiven
kriegshandlungen eingestellt werden sagt
der bundesfinanzminister
dank für das gespräch aber bitte
auch dieses interview haben wir aus
termingründen am frühen abend
aufgezeichnet und aufgrund aktueller
entwicklungen später etwas gekürzt ich
hatte christian lindner auch noch nach
tempolimit und tank rabatt gefragt in
voller länge können sie es online
abrufen auf zdf heute dass wir so
abhängig sind von putins gas und öl
dafür gibt es viele verantwortliche das
war nicht nur eine bundesregierung das
begann unter schröder und ging unter
merkels koalition weiter dabei gab es ja
schon lange genug hinweise darauf mit
wem man es zu tun hat auch schon vor der
annexion der krim und dem krieg in der
ost ukraine
man denke nur an die vielen anschläge
auf kreml gegner unter anderem mit
radioaktiven substanzen von denen manche
sogar ruchlos auf europäischem boden
stattfanden jetzt nach dem überfall auf
die ukraine ist die lernkurve bei
manchen besonders steil oder sollte es
zumindest sein etwa in mecklenburg
vorpommern dazu bernd mosebach
manuela schwesig und ein elektroauto
erster auftritt seit langer zeit mitte
februar hatte sie sich zurückgezogen um
sich um ihre gesundheit zu kümmern jetzt
sechs wochen später ist sie wieder da
und die welt ist eine andere
vorwürfe sie sei bisher zu
russlandfreundlich gab putin freundlich
gewesen hatten sie auch in ihrer reha
erreicht versuch einer klarstellung
erste aufschlag der brutale angriff von
putin auf die ukraine ist durch nichts
zu rechtfertigen das ist ein
kriegsverbrechen putin ist ein
kriegsverbrecher und dieser krieg muss
sofort gestoppt werden zweiter aufschlag
nord stream zwei bis kriegsbeginn hatte
sie sich vehement für das projekt
eingesetzt mit dem wissen von heute war
die unterstützung für nord stream 2 und
die stiftung ein fehler und auch ich
habe diesen fehler gemacht und deshalb
liegt es mir auch am herzen dass jetzt
dieser fehler begradigt wird indem wir
die klimaschutz stiftung auflösen
die klimaschutz stiftung eine idee von
schwesigs damalige rot schwarze
regierung vor einem jahr von allen
parteien im landtag beschlossen auftrag
umweltschutz und die fertigstellung von
nord stream zwei trams sanktionen
sollten so unterlaufen werden das
besondere engagement eines bundeslandes
für ein privatwirtschaftliches projekt
war von anfang an mit vielen
fragezeichen versehen passt aber in die
besondere russlandpolitik im nordosten
der russland tag zb von
spd-ministerpräsident erwin sellering
ins leben gerufen von ex spd kanzler und
gas power manager gerhard schröder
unterstützt allerdings nachfolgerin
spd-ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig
hat die russland kontakte geerbt und
ausgebaut
sellering wiederum hatte den vorsitz der
klimastiftung übernommen für mich war
das keine spd frage ist für mich war das
eine frage als ministerpräsident dafür
zu sorgen dass wir im wirtschaftlichen
aufholprozess gute partner haben das
wahrsagen sich keinen fehler machen dass
man natürlich keine schilder sondern wir
brauchen ein gutes verhältnis zu
russland schlimm ist dass wir uns so
input getäuscht dass er unsere
deutschland ob die stiftung wirklich
aufgelöst werden kann ist unter juristen
noch umstritten auch könnte nord stream
die 20 millionen euro stiftungskapital
zurückfahren schwesig galt zuletzt als
große hoffnung ihrer partei auch auf
bundesebene wurde gar für höchste ämter
gehandelt das ist schon ein
image-schaden der ist jetzt aktuell
vorhanden den hatte jetzt durch die
kehrtwende versucht in den griff zu
bekommen das wird aber nicht reichen
wenn sie denn tatsächlich mal die
nachfolge von herrn scholz antreten will
das muss ich eben jetzt in den nächsten
jahren durch konsequente aufarbeitung
und auch selbstkritik dann in die
richtige richtung lenken zurück auf der
politischen bühne schwesig hat gesagt
was von ihr erwartet wurde nicht mehr
aber auch nicht weniger
jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf weiter
und für soviel sei vorweg gesagt
zumindestens vom arbeitsmarkt kommen
eher positive nachrichten ja die
bundesagentur für arbeit hat heute die
neuen zahlen vorgelegt die märz
statistik die zahl der offenen stellen
steigt die der arbeitslosen sinkt zwei
millionen
362.000 menschen waren demnach ohne job
66.000 weniger als im februar
die quote liegt jetzt bei 5,1 prozent im
vergleich zum märz des vorjahres sind es
465.000 arbeitslose weniger
die ärztegewerkschaft marburger bund
hatte für heute zu warnstreiks in rund
460 kommunalen krankenhäusern aufgerufen
bei der zentralen kundgebung in
frankfurt am main demonstrierten mehrere
tausend ärzten und ärzte für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen gefordert wird zudem
eine erhöhung der gehälter um 5,5
prozent
die quarantäne für corona infizierte und
kontaktpersonen soll offenbar deutlich
verkürzt werden von derzeit zehn auf
fünf tage das geht nach medienberichten
aus einem vorschlag des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums und des
robert koch instituts hervor auch könnte
die strenge isolierung aufgehoben werden
der vorschlag soll demnach jetzt mit den
ländern beraten werden der blick auf die
aktuellen zahlen des rk ii hat 274 1901
neuinfektionen innerhalb eines tages
registriert 43 1486 weniger als
vergangenen donnerstag
279 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents fällt auf
1625,24
dollar seit 30 jahren millionen menschen
sind von hunger bedroht die vereinten
nationen hatten nun auf einer virtuellen
geberkonferenz zur unterstützung für das
land aufgerufen und vier milliarden euro
seien für humanitäre hilfe dringend
nötig sagte un-generalsekretär gut er
ist das geld soll direkt an
hilfsorganisationen und nicht an die
radikalislamischen taliban
deutschland will sich mit 200 millionen
euro beteiligen
wir schalten zur börse war der behala
rund um den ölpreis gab es heute eine
ganze reihe von nachrichten der ölpreis
fällt ja schon seit einigen tagen aber
heute noch mal ganz deutlich hintergrund
ist dass die amerikaner massiv ihre
erdöl reserven anzapfen wollen in einem
bisher nie dagewesenen umfang eine
million barrel täglich ein halbes jahr
lang ein politischer schachzug seitdem
ukraine krieg sind die ölpreise kräftig
gestiegen ein problem für beiden die
hohen spritpreise chmelar nämlich die
beliebtheitswerte und im november stehen
kongresswahlen an diese große menge öl
wird sich auch auf dem weltmarkt
auswirken darum wurde öl heute auch
schon in erwartung der ankündigung
deutlich günstiger wenngleich immer noch
auf hohem niveau auch an den deutschen
tankstellen sind die preise schon leicht
gefallen was aber auch damit zu tun
haben könnte dass das kartellamt gerade
auch die mineralölkonzerne auf ihre
preisbildung abklopft grundsätzlich aber
geht man davon aus dass die
energiepreise und damit auch das öl
längerfristig hoch bleiben und tanken
erstmal teuer bleibt
vielen dank
die staatsanwaltschaft leipzig hat
anklage gegen den musiker gavin erhoben
wegen des tatvorwurfs der falschen
verdächtigung und verleumdung das
landgericht leipzig muss nunmehr über
die zulassung der anklage und die
eröffnung des hauptverfahrens
entscheiden außerdem hatte im
vergangenen oktober in einem video aus
einem hotelmitarbeiter vorgeworfen in
antisemitisch beleidigt zu haben der
fall hatte weltweit für schlagzeilen
gesorgt der vorwurf offerings ließ sich
nach angaben der staatsanwaltschaft so
nicht erhärten
beim wetter hat der norden deutschlands
heute früh schon mal abbekommen was
viele andere regionen noch erwartet der
winter das nochmal zurück bis zu zehn
zentimeter neuschnee lagen zum beispiel
in hamburg zum leidwesen der autofahrer
diejenigen die den schlitten noch nicht
eingemottet haben dagegen ihren spaß
das war es von uns gereicht hatte wetter
geht es weiter bei maybrit illner heute
auch endlich wieder mit maybrit illner
bei ihr zu gast ist unter anderem die
bundesverteidigungsministerium und um
0.30 meldet sich dann christopher
wehrmann mit dem heutigen update hier
erwarten sie morgen abend christian
sievers und hanna zimmermann auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter heute gabs im norden ja schon
eine geschlossene schneedecke und noch
mehr schnee kündigt sich an mit diesem
kleinen tiefe was den schnee schon
brachte das zieht allmählich weiter in
den süden und es wird dann der mitte und
dann morgen vor allem auch im süden
schneit geschuldet ist dieses tief der
tatsache dass wir die eisige luft aus
dem norden bekommen die strömt weiter in
den süden wird begrenzt von dem
jetstream das ist das stark wind band in
zehn kilometer höhe was diese luftmasse
begrenzt in der nacht gibt es in diesem
bereich wo es rot schraffiert ist
teilweise schneeglätte oder
überfrierende nässe es wird also klarer
auf den straßen nach norden hin da ist
es aufgelockert teilweise mit etwas
bewölkung im süden allerdings da regnet
es und in den bergen dort geht es
allmählich in schnee über temperaturen
sinken auf minus zwei grad in der mitte
und 5 grad in bayern und morgen dann im
tagesverlauf in der mitte weiterer
schnee vor allem in den bergen und der
regen im süden der geht ebenfalls
langsam in schnee über es bildet sich
eine schneedecke aus nach norden hin ist
es relativ freundlich teils mit längerem
sonnenschein temperaturen dazu mit
höchstwerten von minus 1 grad nach osten
0 grad im hessischen bergland sonst im
norden fünf bis acht grad und 8 grad
gibt es auch in bayern die nächsten tage
am samstag vor allem im süden noch
schneefall an den alpen des lässt
allmählich nach und dann kommt die sonne
mehr und mehr hervor bei minus 1 bis 9
grad damit ein schöner ort